welcome back to las vegas now if this
thanksgiving you're trying to make the
perfect turkey smith food and drug the
sponsors of this segment are sharing
some secrets to ensure that it's perfect
take a look
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from smith
so the holidays are coming up and
turkey's on the menu and what i'm going
to do today is just kind of give a
refresher on how to get the the
crispiest juiciest turkey that you can
have okay the first important thing i
would have to say is to give yourself
about seven days before thanksgiving
because you need to get that frozen
turkey thawed put that frozen turkey in
your fridge at least for four days so
that it can get nice and thought next
thing we're going to do is put it in a
brine that helps in the juiciness of the
turkey now brine is simply a mixture of
sugar salt and then water that you
cook this or dissolve the sugar and salt
in some hot water and then once you've
done that put your turkey in there and
then
have it go overnight uh and that's what
i have here my turkey's been brined let
me get it out of the brine the next
thing that we want to do is make sure
that our turkey's dry
once i get him out
he's all nice and thawed because i want
to make sure he's dry so probably the
best way to dry a turkey out is just let
it sit in the fridge for another day
outside of the brine and let that skin
really dry out if you don't have that
kind of time then get a paper towel like
this and just dry it off as best you can
because that's going to help us get the
crispiest skin that we can and that's
what we want so once it's all dry
then i want to put some butter on it
and i'm just using softened butter and
then i'm just going to start rubbing it
all over inside the skin
just everywhere just get that butter
rubbing on there
okay our turkey's all buttered up now
i'm going to season all i want to is
kosher salt and pepper
and load it on there nicely put it down
inside the cavity as well and just get
it just get it everywhere you don't need
anything special if you want to put
something in the cavity you can but i
don't really think that that affects the
flavor too much if you want go ahead but
get it nice and salt and peppered
beautiful we've got it in there we want
to set our oven to 400 degrees which
we're at
we want that crispy skin the next most
important part about a juicy turkey is
your temperature set it to 155 and then
put it in the thickest part of the
breast
just like that
and then we're ready for the oven so
let's get it in there
okay so we'll go in the oven we'll set
our
we've got our
thermometer set to 155 and we'll see how
it turns out
okay so our turkey's been in the oven
and we're going to fast forward in time
here magic of tv it's been in for about
two hours it didn't take it very long
but during the process of cooking i've
been basting it with clarified butter or
ghee it's right here you can find that
on the baking aisle or you can make your
own um but it's just butter with the the
the liquids removed from it anyways i've
been basting it with that and that's
going to help that crispy skin so let's
get that turkey out of the oven and see
how it looks
i think it's going to be good
and would you look at that that looks
beautiful
another important thing i didn't mention
was is that we want to cook it to 155
and it came to that 155 looking
beautiful and if you look at it look at
the skin it's crispy i don't know if you
can hear that noise but it's perfect so
i'm so excited happy turkey cookie
cooking you can find all these things at
your local smiths thanks for watching
thanks for shopping and we'll see you
next time everybody bye-bye
there we go all right so thank you to
smith's food and drug for sponsoring
this segment for more information visit
smithfoodanddrug.com now i'm going to
send it over to a bunch of turkeys
this saturday